Well, how did a major crypto lender go from managing billions in assets...
...to filing for bankruptcy in just a matter of months?
Celsius made headlines last month after freezing customer accounts...
...and leaving them in the dark about when or if they would get their money back.
Now for the first time, two former Celsius leaders are revealing...
...what they say led to the company's downfall.
Here's CNBC's Kate Rooney.
Timothy Cradle's career had been about making sure companies follow the rules.
So, he says he was alarmed by conversations at a Celsius corporate event in late 2019.
There was a bit of an odd thing that came up at one of our Christmas parties.
Cradle, the former Director of Financial Crimes Compliance,...
...says top executives were talking about deliberate price movements in a CEL token.
The cryptocurrency created and used by Celsius started to spike in early 2020.
I don't know what better way to phrase it, but they were in the market.
They were actively trading and increasing the price of the token.
Based on those conversations,...
...you’re saying that management was manipulating the price of the Celsius token.
They were absolutely trading the token to manipulate the price.
This echoes claims in a lawsuit,...
...alleging the company was actively using customer funds...
...to manipulate crypto asset markets to their benefit.
Market manipulation is one of the biggest issues in crypto,...
...and it's one of multiple issues former employees are now speaking out about.